as President Biden's mishandling of
classified documents Scandal deepens a
new theory has emerged out of the blue
Anon movement on the left the theory is
that the documents were planted in
Biden's office and home by conservatives
here is the prominent modern political
philosopher of the left Joy Behar
proposing the theory
a luckier person than Donald Trump just
as we're this close to getting them but
you know how
here's the thing Biden is wrong to have
done this
Democrat Congressman Hank Johnson who is
most famous for suggesting that if more
people move to Guam the island might
capsize a Hank Johnson has expounded on
this theory he said quote my response to
it all is that the alleged classified
documents showing up allegedly in the
possession of Joe Biden you know I mean
there's so much that needs to be
investigated and that's that's what I
called for is for everything to be
investigated but I'm suspicious of the
timing of it I'm also aware of the fact
that things can be planted on people
places and things can be planted things
can be planted in places and then
discovered conveniently that may be what
has occurred I'm not ruling that out but
I don't I'm open in terms of the
investigation
needs to be investigated
pithy these Libs might want to be
careful what they wish for because it
now appears that the Biden documents
will be investigated and assuming that
no secret Republican mole turns up in
Joe Biden's garage I don't think the
libs are going to like what the
investigation turns up I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Larry who says
I now text a Ukraine Emoji flag when I
need to borrow money from someone that's
that's a novel way to do it in terms of
all of the excuses that people come up
with when they need to borrow money
that's a a great way to ask for the
money and to Signal your virtue another
great way to save money you gotta switch
to pure talk right now head on over to
puretalk.com use promo code Knowles if
one of your goals this year is to do
business with companies that share your
beliefs and what you hold dear then
check out Pure Talk Pure Talk is the
antidote to woke wireless companies it
is proudly veteran owned employs a
us-based customer service team and
absolutely refuses to spend money on
fake news networks not to mention Pure
Talk service is fantastic they are one
of the largest networks in the country
you get blazing fast data talk and text
for as little as thirty dollars a month
that is probably probably half of what
you're paying Verizon ATT or T-Mobile
right now maybe less switch over to Pure
Talk in as little as 10 minutes super
easy keep your phone keep your phone
number your first month is guaranteed
risk free try it if you're not
completely happy with the service you
get your money back this year make it a
goal to support companies that support
you head on over to puretalk.com enter
promo code noleskin.wles save 50 off
your first month that is puretalk.com
promo code Knowles Canada w-les Pure
Talk is simply smarter Wireless
these documents just keep popping up for
Joe Biden a whole lot of accidents going
on uh Joe Biden has finally responded to
classified documents that were found
from his time as vice president he said
that they were locked in a garage by his
Corvette now these are different
documents than the ones that were locked
in his office at the fake Think Tank
these were at his home how did they get
there that's kind of weird but don't
worry it's right right near the Corvette
no one's going to go near those Richard
Sauber who is special counsel to the
president said in a statement that quote
all but one of these documents were
found in storage space in the
president's Wilmington residence garage
lots of accidents here Whoopsie Daisy
how many more documents are going to
turn up I don't know
but what I do know is that Joe Biden's
current defense in this scandal
is pretty weak
I I think that Joe Biden could make this
Scandal go away right now by saying oh
the documents are unclassified
he could do that because as I said when
the libs were trying to blow up the
Trump document scandal at Mar-A-Lago I
pointed out that the president of the
United States has the right as the
authority to declassify whatever he
wants whenever he wants to do it he does
not need to submit himself to a formal
process to do that
there there is no middle manager
bureaucrat guy who to to whom the
president must write a letter requesting
to declassify documents
the president's the top of the food
chain when it comes to the executive
branch and so if the president did have
to submit himself to some career
bureaucrat in whatever agency you want
that that would be a strange perversion
of the way that the government is
supposed to work so
I said it when they were going after
Trump for this stuff I'll say it now
that we're going after Biden for this
stuff Joe Biden could end this now and
say okay they're Declassified but he
won't do that he won't do that because
that would completely undermine the
argument that the libs have been making
about Donald Trump for months now as
they try to justify the FBI raiding
Mar-A-Lago on Joe Biden's watch so now
he's in this really tough position
because the the Avenue that he has
before him to make all of this go away
he has closed off to himself because he
still wants to keep attacking his
political enemy and for now his chief
rival Donald Trump so the excuse that he
has right now is this was inadvertent
Joe Biden just didn't know
I think it's a weak excuse because
whether he knew or whether he didn't he
mishandled the documents apparently a
lot of documents apparently in multiple
places now what Joe Biden has done is
even if you're just trying to compare
the acts themselves much worse than what
Donald Trump did
Trump did did it as president he took
the documents as President Joe Biden
only took the documents as vice
president when he had no right to
declassify the documents but but also
Trump just kept all those docs in some
closet at Mar-A-Lago Biden now we're
looking at multiple places he said it
was inadvertent but Jonathan Turley who
is a very famous law professor and
commentator on these matters he pointed
out that this defense actually might
work against him he said if Biden worked
off any of these documents for his book
which dealt with some of the underlying
subjects apparently in the documents the
inadvertent defense
is not only shattered but could be
viewed as an effort to deceive the
public and this is
this is the tangled web we weave when
first we practice to deceive
you know this if you've ever told a lie
everybody's told a lie at some point you
tell a lie and then what's what's really
annoying about the LIE is not only that
it it damages your soul to do even that
but then you got to keep up with the LIE
then you got to remember who you told
which lie to and who knows what and who
thinks this and then you've got to keep
the lie going and Joe Biden is
the most prominent habitual liar in the
United States George Santos that
republican from Long Island might unseat
him
from that ground because George Santos
lied about his education background his
professional background and possibly his
sexual desires but put a pause in that
for right now Joe Biden has been doing
it a lot longer he had to drop out of
the 1988 presidential race for lying
the guy's a liar now it's catching up
with him and what Liars think is okay
I'm in this Jam right now well I'll just
tell a lie and that'll get me that will
get me out of the jam but as Charlie
points out Biden's lies on this subject
could get him in more trouble
so that the
the options before him are
keep up the LIE potentially get himself
in actual legal trouble because
the president of the United States can't
mishandle classified documents by
definition but he can perjure himself he
can't obstruct an investigation he can
do lots of other things that he may or
may not be doing right now that's one
Avenue available to him or the other is
admit that the Trump
nonsense about the classified documents
was precisely that it was all just an
empty political attack and move on and
right now the Democrats can't let go
they hate Trump so much they are willing
to put themselves in a very dicey
political and legal position to do it
so what's what's going to happen to
Biden well Merrick Garland the Attorney
General is appointing a special counsel
I'm here today to announce the
appointment of Robert Herr as a special
counsel pursuant to Department of
Justice regulations governing such
matters
in keeping with those regulations I have
today notified the designated members of
each house of Congress of the
appointment on the evening of November
4th 2022 the National Archives office of
Inspector General
contacted a prosecutor at the Department
of Justice
it informed him that the White House had
notified the archives that documents
bearing classification markings were
identified at the office of the Penn
Biden Center for diplomacy and Global
engagement
located in Washington DC
that office was not authorized for
storage of classified documents
the prosecutor was also advised that
those documents had been secured in an
archives facility
on November 9th the FBI commenced an
assessment consistent with standard
protocols to understand whether
classified information had been
mishandled in violation of federal law
wait a second is Merrick Garland
principled now is Merrick Garland a
conservative now is Merrick Garland
willing to go after his own side and and
execute Justice blindly
I don't really believe that I'm I'm
encouraged to see what he's done right
now Garland has appointed this U.S
attorney former U.S attorney Robert Herr
who does not appear to be some big lib
lawyer he actually appears to be a
Republican and he actually appears to be
a conservative not just a swish
Republican but this guy served in the
Trump Administration he served as
special counsel in the investigation
after the U.S attorney for Northern
district of Illinois John lausch
recommended to Garland that that
happened he clerked for the former
Supreme Court chief justice William
rehnquist who was extremely conservative
so
this is actually pretty good I'm always
looking for what's the angle here is
this guy a secret squish you remember
when when the doj appointed Robert
Mueller to go after Trump they said well
he's a republican but Robert Mueller is
a total swamp creature kind of
establishment squishy Republican he's
not a Conservative Republican can't
imagine he liked Trump all that much
why is this happening
the only angle I can see on it is
disappointment reflects
Joe Biden's relative weakness
in the Democrat Party
and that is really bad news for Joe and
it's really good news for all the rest
of us
now Joe Biden is coming to the end of
his
term in office I hope that will be the
the end of his whole political career
you and I are all going to come to our
end at some point one day that's why you
got to check out epic will right now
head on over to epicwill.com use promo
code nulls it can be tough to stick to
your New Year's resolution you set out
with lofty goals stick to them for two
weeks and then fall right back into your
old habits lucky for you I've got a goal
you can accomplish today
complete your will with epic will for
just 119 dollars and in as little as
five minutes epic will can help you
create your last will and testament
living will and even Health Care power
of attorney their step-by-step online
form makes it incredibly easy all you
need to do is fill in the blanks very
important to have a will I know
everybody puts it off don't life comes
at you fast man death comes like a thief
in the night okay make sure that you
know where your stuff is going and
especially if you have kids what's going
to happen to your kids fifty percent of
Americans don't have a will choose today
to be in the smarter half go to
epicwell.com use promo code Knowles to
save 10 on Epic Wheels complete will
package epicwill.com promo code
k-n-o-w-l-e-s because you will die I'm
promising you you will die no one here
gets out alive and so make sure that you
are prepared epicwill.com promo code
Knowles A.G Merritt Garland appointing a
special counsel to investigate Joe Biden
over the classified documents represents
I think Biden's weakness in the party I
also think even if Biden were very
strong in the Democrat Party right now
Garland probably would have had to do
this not because the issue is all that
big a deal but because the Democrats
were just making such a huge hullabaloo
about Trump doing a lesser version of
the same alleged crime so they had to do
it it would have looked so transparently
corrupt had had Garland not done this I
think Garland recognizes the House GOP
just took control of the of the lower
house of Congress and so he doesn't want
to get hauled before congressional
committees and chewed out by the
Republicans who are now running those
committees so there are a lot of
political reasons why he had to do it
but also if Joe Biden were dominating
the Democrat Party right now this would
not have happened
you think about how Trump found himself
in a similar situation with special
counsel the reason for that is Trump did
not have a total control over the
Republican Party he obviously won the
nomination in 2016 he won the presidency
in 2016 but he won the people over I
think in 2016 but the party apparatus
still hated that guy's guts the never
Trump part of the party but also just
the old kind of swamp creatures Trump
came in like a bull in a China Chef they
did not like him and so that part of the
GOP consistently tried to undermine
Donald Trump what we're seeing right now
is that Joe Biden is just not that
popular with Democrats Democrats don't
think that the guy can win in 2024 and
so if you're looking right now and and
Joe Biden is just not making good
excuses for these classified documents
they come in a terrible time for him to
give Joy Behar Purdue
she's right the timing just looks
absolutely awful and so if you're a
Democrat and you're making a bet do I
defend Biden here or do I throw him to
the Wolves probably you're going to be
more inclined to throw them to the
Wolves okay Biden's past his expiration
date time to move on from this guy
speaking of moving on speaking of
becoming disillusioned disenchanted with
things we once loved at the political
level
only 16 percent of Jen Sears love
America this according to a new morning
consult survey released this week shows
that when asked about how they view
living in their country gen Z adults had
extremely low opinions of the United
States well 52 percent of all U.S adults
said they were proud to live in America
only 16 of gen Z agreed compare this
with the Boomers almost three out of
every four Boomers say that they love
America proud to live in America uh more
than half of gen xers 54 say they love
America even the Millennials who
basically hate America say that they're
proud of their country love their
country and then just one in six
less than one and six Zoomers say that
they love their country I am not
surprised at all not merely because the
youths these days those youths they
don't know how good they got it when I
was a kid you know I trudged uphill both
ways in the snow and the sleet and the
fire and the brimstone these kids
they're so soft they don't it's not just
that
the reason that I'm not surprised at all
that gen Z doesn't love their country is
that nobody is really defending the
country as a country we know that the
libs hate America we know that the libs
say that America is an evil racist
sexist this is thatist phobic place
that's always been oppressive and
terrible to all sorts of people and
we've got to topple the statues of our
forebearers and we should shred the
Constitution and we should start over
because of how terrible this place is so
there you go right off
basically half of gen Z right there
that's the way that the libs are
educated today that wasn't exactly true
for the Boomers the Boomers became
disaffected with America and
disillusioned but they weren't educated
that way they were educated to love
their country and then
you're seeing declining national love
and national pride after that but okay
write off at least half of the Zoomers
all those lives
even the conservatives I think
are educated today not to love their
country
I think that over the last 30 40 years
the way that even the young
conservatives have been raised is to
think not what can I do for my country
but what can my country do for me
they've been raised to believe that at
the heart of politics is the individual
that's what politics is really about and
the government the nation such as it is
only exists so that I can get more stuff
the whole point of the government the
reason those founding fathers and
framers of the Constitution went through
all that trouble was just to set up a
system where the government doesn't mean
anything and the nation has no unified
purpose and there's no such thing as the
common good that's commie talk if you
ask me and the whole reason the thing
exists is just to get people to leave me
alone and get off my lawn and let me
keep my money that's what government's
for that's what the the polity
representing the whole nation is for
just about me getting more stuff
I'm barely exaggerating
so okay you got the libs naturally hate
their country and they want to erase the
borders and erase any sense of natural
inheritance or identity
but you got the conservatives basically
neglecting national identity
and being raised in a fanatically small
government borderline anarchistic kind
of uh ideology that even if it is not
put in practice does go into the minds
of the young people who have been raised
in it
and so ideas like the common good ideas
like a shared National purpose ideas
like the Republic Republic comes from
race publica stuff we hold in common
things we have in common the ideas like
the sumum bonum this was an idea that
before the enlightenment before the
modern live philosophers came around
people understood that that politics has
existed in part at least to pursue good
and avoid evil that was what it was
about and then after the enlightenment
you have this big shift to a view of the
polity as just a a big social contract
where the main thing that the government
is supposed to do is get everyone to
leave everybody else alone and we have
no shared pursuit of the common good we
can't even really identify what the
common good is all we can identify is
the common bad this is what Thomas Hobbs
writes about in Leviathan and you see
shades of this throughout all of the
liberal writers who come afterward we
don't who knows what's good you know
what you say is good maybe I don't think
is good but we do know what's bad and
what's bad is when you take my property
and so as a result of that we've got to
just have a government that protects
certain
basically material rights and then all
that virtue stuff that goes out the
window okay well if you're going to
throw all that virtue stuff out the
window people aren't going to love their
country
if you're going to throw out the notion
that there is anything lovable about the
country as a country
then people aren't going to love it it's
not the zoomer's fault I hate to defend
the Zoomers but it's not their fault
but it is an embarrassment and we've got
to fix it now speaking of national
embarrassments George Santos
George Santos the Republican congressman
who claimed to be Jewish though
his defense was he never claimed to be
Jewish he claimed to be Catholic but he
said he had Jewish ancestry which meant
he was Jewish which is a funny line
people are pretending to be offended by
it but it's a very very funny line and
if it were just that you might say okay
he said he had a Jewish great grandpa or
something somewhere maybe maybe he did
maybe that's in the family tree maybe
there was a Jewish Milkman walking
around Brazil or wherever the Santos are
from I don't know whatever maybe it
could be but then more lies kept coming
up he lied about his education he said
that he went to NYU he sent he said he
went to Baruch College he said he went
to Horace Mann before College none of
that seems to be true he said he works
for Goldman Sachs that doesn't seem to
be true
he he said he's a gay guy but until two
weeks before his first congressional run
in 2020 he was married
to a woman so now we don't believe this
guy and there's pressure on Kevin
McCarthy
to boot him out of Congress
Kevin McCarthy now Speaker of the House
says
he will continue to serve
George Santos says I'm not resigning and
Kevin McCarthy says I'm not going to
make him resign
and why how does Kevin McCarthy justify
keeping George Santos in the House of
Representatives
he told reporters yeah okay he's lied
so have a lot of people here in the
Senate and others
Now Kevin McCarthy he's not the leader
in the Senate George Santos is not the
Senate why does he say that he is
obviously referring to Elizabeth Warren
yeah George Santos seems to have made up
a ton of stuff about his biography
because he claims to be a Native
American
has he Advanced his career by being the
whitest woman to ever walk the earth and
pretending to be
Pocahontas no I don't think so
has he did he lie about his academic
record yeah oh I guess he can be
president now Okay Kevin McCarthy said
hold on the bar
the bar now to be kicked out of Congress
as you embellish your back you lie about
your background you embellish your
resume okay I guess we got to kick out
everybody in Congress then and
specifically the Democrats who have done
this brazenly in recent years and I
gotta say I totally agree with Kevin
McCarthy here I wouldn't trust George
Santos for anything I wouldn't trust him
to get me a cup of coffee but I wouldn't
tell him to resign we've got a razor
thin House Majority right now and the
Democrats never resign when they get
caught in these embarrassments tell you
what we'll make a deal once Elizabeth
Warren resigns for pretending to be
Sitting Bull then George Santos can
resign for lying about all of his
background
okay and then if that doesn't happen
then Congressman Santos I hope you do a
great job voting for good conservative
principles and allowing the Republicans
to keep their majority you know today
is the anniversary of one of the
greatest moments in Daily wires history
after months of leading the legal battle
against federal government and a
national do not comply campaign the
Supreme Court blocked the Biden
administration's outrageous vaccine
mandate this mandate would have set a
dangerous precedent giving the unelected
OSHA organization power over the
personal medical decisions of American
citizens the Supreme Court recognized
this gross power grab and made the right
decision and we are so so happy to have
led the charge in this fight but we
could not have done that without you
thousands of you joined the daily wire
and over a million Americans signed our
petition against the mandates to
celebrate we are offering 40 off our
annual memberships with the code do not
comply
this was a really big deal because when
this mandate came down
it's very easy to say well we're not
we're not going to go along with it they
can't make us I'm going to need fauci to
show up here himself and stick that
thing in my arm
except
the alternative had we not one in the
Supreme Court would have been they just
shut down the company so we could talk a
good game but if the court had upheld
That vaccine mandate then what would
have happened was OSHA would have come
in especially the daily wire which is a
big political Target and they would have
said oh you're not making your employees
take the fauciatchi okay we're going to
charge you thousands and thousands of
dollars every single day for every
single employee who's not doing it you
would have had
hundreds of thousands of dollars maybe a
day
but certainly within a week hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of dollars I would
have added up I think within two weeks
they would have bankrupted the company
and that's that so we fought back and we
fought back because you allowed us to
fight back so today we celebrate get 40
off your annual membership dailywire.com
subscribe join the winning team as we
continue to crush the left do not comply
forty percent off is the code do not
comply
speaking of gay stuff
a Penn State sociology Professor has
encouraged his students to watch gay
porn
he's not just encouraged his gay
students gay identifying LGBT
identifying students to watch LGBT porn
he's encouraging all of his students to
do that
what's the argument
this is from sociology 119 Professor Sam
Richards says that that
even straight people and especially
straight people should watch gay porn
because they might be aroused by it he
says if you're straight watch gay or
lesbian porn see how quickly you feel
aroused and how you can't control that
you'll realize oh expletive I could be
sexualized by people who are like me
went on to say we are all at some level
non-binary
we're all very much easily bisexual
uh it's not clear what he's pointing to
in terms of the research that would lead
him to this conclusion there was a study
uh conducted by Cornell in 2015 showed
or claimed at least that both men and
women were aroused when they watched
porn of the same sex and they said that
this is evidence that everybody's gay or
something everybody's bisexual you know
that thing that totally exists
bisexuality yeah they said that that
everybody was that and the professor
said I might have hit a nerve there did
I hit a nerve
watch gay porn he said see if you feel
that feeling if you feel that feeling
look in a mirror say huh maybe I'm just
feeling some things that I'm just afraid
to release and maybe you release that
and maybe you'd be surprised that maybe
you actually are fine being more
bisexual
and he said he says I have friends who
have spent a long time in prison I'm
sure he has I think that's the only
thing he said so far that's true I have
friends that's been a long time in
prison and they have homosexual sex
they're straight until they're in prison
and then they do that so especially on
the prison point I think what he's
observing is
true enough he's saying yeah you throw a
bunch of guys in prison there's not a
woman in sight and they're all a little
bit deviant to begin with they're
criminals and they're all they're doing
all day long is working out and they've
got testosterone pumping through them
and they've got all these kind of social
hierarchies and the ordinary order of
society goes completely insane and
surprise surprise you get some eccentric
sexual acts going on yeah that's true
that does happen important that's a
punch line or that does happen in prison
rather it's a punch line when people go
to prison you say oh I don't drop the
soap
but how does this relate to porn
saying if you turn on a gay porno you
might feel aroused
regardless of a stu if of whether or not
a student does feel aroused watching
from that kind of pornography
this is what grooming is
when when conservatives talk about
grooming this is what we're talking
about we're not just talking about some
drag queen weirdo leading a
five-year-old off into the woods by the
hands we're talking about this kind of
stuff what is grooming grooming is when
you cultivate sexual desire in somebody
else
it's not just that you go in and
violently take that person it's when you
are cultivating that desire the
professor is saying hey you're a
straight guy you don't think about doing
gay stuff well maybe you should maybe
you should actually engage in an
activity that is designed not merely to
satisfy sexual desires but to cultivate
them because that's what pornography
does that's what the Indulgence of all
lust does
this is why when you hear people talk
about pornography addiction and The
Perils of the industry and even the way
that the industry makes money the way it
makes money is on the basis that
pornography does not satiate lust it
inflames lust it encourages lust and it
leads people down really weird Alleyways
people who have have become to identify
as transgender and then they leave
transgenderism
lots and lots of them I would I would be
comfortable saying the vast majority of
them that I have heard or read of say
that porn was involved in some way
I said I started off watching kind of
normal-ish porn and then I started
watching weirder and weirder porn and
then eventually I started watching porn
that told me that I'm a woman
so it's cultivating that desire what
does this professor even think that
bisexual means
if you're a guy and you never think
about doing weird stuff with guys and
you never engage in weird stuff with
guys and you're perfectly attracted to
women and that's what's going on
throughout your whole life
and then this professor sits you down in
a chair and plays a bunch of gay porn
for you and then at the end of whatever
time period let's say at the end of six
months of this you start to have more
disordered sexual visions and desires
that means you're bisexual no it means
that guy made you bisexual it means that
guy encouraged that the desires in you
because he's making a normative
statement he's saying that is good it's
good to be gay it's good to be bisexual
it's good and it's bad not to be
it's like it's not just it's okay to be
gay it's not just not that there's
anything wrong with that which was the
kind of 1990s laissez-faire attitude to
these sexual questions
it's a claim that is that it is actively
good to pursue disordered sexual desires
and and why are people claiming this
it's not just because they're
sexual deviants like this professor
it it follows naturally from the
liberationist theology that has told us
in increasingly absurd ways for the last
several centuries that we need to free
our true selves
not merely from the oppressive shackles
of tyrannical governments but from
convention from morality from our
families from our physical bodies
from our religion certainly but even
from our bodies because my true self is
not my body
I've got it that's the argument
that people are making
and it's a false one I mean it's it's
whatever this professor has to say about
the psychological effects of porn he
probably knows a thing or two about it
because I'm sure he's watched a lot of
it
he doesn't know anything about ethics
morality he doesn't seem to know very
much about anthropology doesn't seem to
know very much about Theology and and he
is he is smuggling in all of those
theological philosophical
anthropological premises in this
Preposterous sort of class now back to
Congress for a second the House GOP has
just passed a great Bill where amid the
the moral confusion of our whole culture
right now the House GOP has come in and
and said no we are going to say that
there's a difference between good and
bad true and false friend and enemy and
we're going to operate on that basis it
involves
energy really important energy issues
we'll we'll get to more of that
unfortunately we can't get to it right
now we'll have to wait to get to that
next week and we'll have to get to the
other important energy issue which is
the labs are coming for your gas stoves
we'll also have to wait to get to that
do you know why because I want to get to
the mailbag the mailbag is sponsored by
Pure Talk go to puretalk.com select a
plan and enter code Knowles kwles to get
50 off your first month
take it away with the voicemail back
hey Michael love the show uh today I'm
coming to you with a grave moral
quandary uh back when in the summer when
the yes or no game first got put on The
Daily wire website I pre-ordered it
didn't deliver until a week or so before
Christmas but that's okay but because of
that my wife did not know I had got a
copy and ordered me one and put it under
our Christmas tree as a gift
um
when we realized what had happened I I
realized I had committed a grave moral
sin I I have stolen a second copy of the
yes or no game and kept of creme de La
Creme member of the Michael Knowles show
uh without a a yes or no game uh how can
I how can I remedy this situation should
I send it back should I give it to a
family member
um
can I trade it in for a couple copies of
controlling words controlling Minds to
give to my family uh what what thoughts
do you have on this and and am I banned
from the show for this moral atrocity uh
thanks a bunch and keep up the good work
thank you for your honesty thank you I
appreciate that it it you're not banned
from the show but this is a grave
problem because lots and lots of people
want the yes or no game it's sold out in
a Flash the daily wire has ordered more
copies or is in the process of getting
more copies of the yes or no game the
greatest new game to hit the market in
decades if not centuries and they're
already selling out very very quickly so
if you do want to pre-order head on over
to the Daily wire plus workshop and
pre-order it right now because they will
sell out
but what can you do now
you have accidentally ordered two copies
you have deprived an inner circle creme
de La Creme all-access member of the
game of their hearts desire what I would
recommend you do is buy a third copy
because if you as you suggest give the
second copy away to say Your mother well
what's your father going to say
what's your your father's gonna say
where's my copy so you're going to want
to give an additional one to him maybe
if you really want to remedy it I would
order four or five copies of the game
now I would I would just drop them off
at your friends and family's homes your
conservative friends
your liberal friends maybe especially
that would be a good way to get started
next question
hey Michael it's me again nick uh first
off I just want to let you know your
advice regarding my friend and well
letting her drive was very doubtful and
it's been dealt with
I got a new question for you that
gosh it's a bit sensitive
um
I'm gonna level with you I have a
younger sister who I often try and keep
on the DL due to all the Chad level
kings that I hang out with and how many
of them take a pass at her
my sister and I we have a good
brother-sister relationship in the past
and I've managed to keep her under the
radar until recently
last year she started posting more on
Instagram and went from posting workout
photos to swimsuit photos and now those
turned in thirst trap which have grown a
profile at the thought level
oh gosh my question is
when does posting on Insta turn to only
fans light I mean when do I cut this off
before my Sigma dude starts simping on
her or Worse end up being some of her
first subscribers to a real only fans
uh which would force me to change my
name and move to Puerto Rico
thanks Michael love the show
whoever is behind this Nick character
which I'm beginning to think Nick I
don't I don't know if I buy your whole
backstory but who Nick has
popped up every now and whoever is
behind the character might be the
greatest actor and thespian of Our
Generation I said the other day that
Dylan Mulvaney is the greatest actor of
Our Generation because he's really
taking on the character of of a girl
whoever
whoever is I have to say with Nick I
first I didn't know is this a real
person I don't know maybe it is a real
but who I it's a good question you raise
a good question at what point
does Instagram become only fans light
the moment you download the app that is
when it becomes only fans life okay the
whole point of Instagram is just to put
enticing pictures in front of your eyes
and have you just Doom scroll forever uh
it's probably drooling it doesn't even
have to be bikini shots it could be when
when it comes to my Instagram do you
know what is mostly on my Instagram I've
got my friends and things like that you
know catch up oh look at so and so's
little baby but in terms of what the
algorithm is serving to me so that I
will continue to watch it because I'm so
attracted to these pictures
these big bowls of Italian food my
Instagram feed is largely Hoagies bowls
of pasta
things that that really do entice me and
then I sit there and I do them scroll
forever it is a kind of pornography in
that this is content it might not be
what the Penn State Professor wants to
consider is pornography and get
everybody to watch but it's a kind of
pornography in that when when I'm going
through my feed and I just see different
bowls of Italian food I am it's not
edifying me I'm I'm not growing in
wisdom by looking at this it's simply
satisfying my appetite in a virtual way
it's it's not even satisfying my
appetite in a real way it's not not
satisfying my body just as porn doesn't
satisfy your appetite and your lusts in
a in a real way it does so in a in a
virtual way and and so I I would
strongly recommend if you can use
Instagram in a way that
you feel as virtuous and conducive to
flourishing do it I have rarely seen
that happen and so I would sit your
sister down and and explain your
concerns about your uh Chad level King
Bros and how you fear they will simp for
her
next question
hey Michael I have a question about your
views on the Broadway show Hamilton long
story short I just want to let you know
that I find it kind of insulting to
minorities
Broadway which is usually a a white
dominated culture granted right a lot of
white people go to see Broadway shows we
had to make sure that minorities felt so
good about themselves that we had to put
a show out there that specifically only
will hire minorities for specific lead
roles even though that they represent
white people of the past and we did all
of this to say that we recognize that if
we had the same kind of acceptance of
minorities back then as we do now that
yes we could have had a black guy as
George Washington Alexander Hamilton
could have been Hispanic Etc
I mean if I was a minority race and I
went to see Hamilton I just want to see
the honest story of Hamilton I don't
want to be pandered to that would be my
thought I'm just curious if you feel the
same way and I'm curious any other
additional thoughts about that Broadway
show that you have thanks
you know I made a similar Point actually
on the show yesterday which was the
actor kumal nanjiani was complaining
about how he doesn't get to play a
villain because Hollywood won't cast
non-white people as villains
so what what Hollywood says what the
liberal culture says is
the bad guys have to be white
that white people bad non-white people
good and so you might say well that's
flattering to
non-white people but it's not because
it's denying the full Humanity of
non-white people because we know that
mankind has fallen we know that people
are imperfect and so if you say
non-white people can't be the villain
then you're saying that non-white people
are just the passive victims of the real
human beings who are the white people
the only people with agency are the
white people according to this View and
then um non-white people don't have it
so that that is offensive though that
was not the point of Hamilton
the point of Hamilton and its decision
to cast all non-white people in these
roles was one to give non-white people
more roles two to
sideline white people and to sort of
subtly disparage white people I think
which is throughout the popular culture
and three the the charitable view of why
Hamilton did that is that it was
partaking of a liberal concept called
colorblind casting
Hamilton wasn't really colorblind
casting in that it wasn't hey the best
guy gets the job Hamilton said hey all
the all the actual historical white
people are going to be played by blacks
and Hispanics except for the villain of
the story King George he's the only one
who gets to be white actually proves
kumal nanjiani's point
but the the concept of colorblind
casting which is the kind of facade in
front of that Joe uh was a liberal
concept that says that any any person of
any race can play any part because these
players are talking to The Human
Condition except it only ever seems to
cut one way
so yes it's it a black actor can play
Macbeth because they say well Macbeth is
just about the human condition but white
people are never allowed to play Black
characters
and not all people on the left support
colorblind casting August Wilson who's
probably the most important black
playwright of the last century he's the
one behind fences which was turned into
a movie with Denzel Washington a few
years ago ma rainey's black bottom two
trains run and lots of plays
Century cycle
August Wilson said I hate colorblind
casting let the white people play the
white parts and let the black people
play the Black Parts he which is a
legitimate view he's saying that in
order for the theater to convey the
truth of the play you can't have white
people playing blacks and blacks playing
whites
that that's a view but it's not the view
of the Liberals it's it's a little bit
where you can kind of see
the Horseshoe Theory coming around there
are going to be people on the right and
people on the left who hold that view
but the mainstream liberal view for now
is at least some form of colorblind
casting next question
hi Michael this is Annie in Pennsylvania
I just wanted to let you know that your
ukulele videos inspired me to buy a
ukulele and to learn to play I do not
know any instruments
um and I have just mastered my first few
chords and playing You Are My Sunshine
just wondering if you have any tips or
tricks on learning and what your
favorite beginner song is for me to
learn thanks
I'm so pleased to hear that I'm glad
that I can evangelize the ukulele it is
my favorite instrument that I play in
part because you can just pick it up and
play it anywhere you don't need to sit
down you don't need to open up the piano
or take out the even the big guitar and
sit on a spec you just you can have the
ukulele anywhere when I'm walking around
my house chasing my son around doing
whatever I just have the ukulele and you
can kind of mindlessly play it four
strings very simple to learn how to play
if you already play guitar it's like the
top four strings on a guitar except that
the the G string which is fulfilling the
role of the D string on the guitar is an
octave up it's it's tuned to different
notes but the the
chord patterns will will be the same as
on a guitar so you can do that if you're
if you're familiar with that
um
but I don't just mess around with it
that's all I would recommend that you do
I love you are my sunshine it's a great
great song and now when I play songs on
ukulele when I was a kid I would I would
look it up on well we didn't really have
YouTube tutorials then back in the old
days back when I was a kid so you'd look
up tabulature or you'd look up different
kind of notes to figure out how to play
it but now I just just pluck it out it's
more of the 90 of the fun of the ukulele
is just kind of plucking plucking out
the song so you're my sunshine great
place to start
a written mailbag
from Anne
hello Michael
I'm a daily Watcher of your show and I
love it thank you Ann appreciate that
my sister and I are both nursing mothers
and are invited to our friend's wedding
we mentioned that our friend to our
friend that we will need to bring our
babies due to nursing and he acted like
it would not be a problem but said he'd
double check with the bride here we go
here we go City double check with the
bride we just found out that she does
not want our babies there because she
doesn't want them to be a distraction
and it's not the atmosphere they're
going for my sister said we'd sit in the
back and step out if the babies became
too loud but the bride is standing by
her answer this hurt my sister and I
pretty deeply our friend is like a
brother and we hate to miss his wedding
but our babies come first do you think
it's okay for a bride to say a nursing
mother cannot bring her infant baby to
the wedding thanks for your time Leslie
Eck
oh no leslik is the next question that
in the teleprompter was uh right up
there with the older okay so this is
from Anne uh thanks for your time okay
I hate to sound like a big lib here
but
I think the bride has the right to say
no kids
I know it's not traditional I know it's
not conservative I know it's not
promoting family values in a certain way
to say we don't want kids at our wedding
but I understand it depending on the
venue depending on the hour of the night
depending on the dress if it's black tie
and ball gowns it's probably a little
weird to have a baby there even if the
baby has to nurse and so I get I'm not
saying I defend it and I'm not saying I
defend the husband the fiance here just
rolling over to his soon-to-be bride uh
that that's a separate problem probably
but but if they make that decision I
think that decision is totally up to
them and so what can you do well you and
your your sister could
have a babysitter you know either a
family member or other maybe the family
members going to the wedding or a
babysitter come and watch both of the
kids and just give bottles to the kids
you know get enough milk ready that you
can feed the kids for a couple of hours
or sit or sit at the wedding in this
very short period of life where the
babies are nursing a lot and are really
young that's that's what happens kids
inconvenience Our Lives all the time
that is part of being a parent
and you might you might have other
problems with this bride if she's
throwing her weight around and telling
her soon-to-be husband that he can't
have his friends at the wedding or
whatever I mean that's a separate issue
but in terms of can a can a couple say
no kids
they can and it's and in some but not
all cases they're perfectly
right to do so
the rest of the show continues now I
want to get to a little bit more from
from the mailbag and then of course it
is fake headline Friday this is where I
need your help you not you Hoy polloi
that are watching on whatever public
platform I'm talking about you the creme
de La Creme the Inner Circle the
all-access members the Michael Knowles
show member segment real VIPs I need
your help to help me discern which is
the fake headline and which are the four
real headlines Mr Davies is really
trying to confound me so become a member
today use code Knowles Canada w-l-e-s at
checkout for two months free on a all
access plan any daily wire plan you want
dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles at checkout
[Music]
foreign
[Music]